Major school districts around the country
are searching for new superintendents.
In the process, everyone is looking for an
“innovator”—someone with new and exciting ideas.
But along the way, a simple truth is too often
lost: We forget that success in any organization,
is mostly a matter of precision, discipline,
and focus.
Exciting ideas are only as good as their execution.
Too often in the search for innovation, districts
swing back and forth between new programs,
and don’t do any of them especially well.
Teachers and students get swamped by a tide
of ceaseless, half-serious change.
Some district is inevitably embracing reform
A and rejecting B as misguided . . . just
as another is latching onto B as shiny
and new, and discarding reform A as old and tired.
Here’s a suggestion: Don’t ask who's "innovative"
and don't look for a "change agent."
There's nothing wrong with any of that, but it's a distraction.
What matters much more than what leaders promise
to do for kids is how they are going to do it.
What do you think districts should look for in a superintendent?
Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.